he's the only one with all of us that he  can tell you something and then he plays  10 hours of it and then that's what it  was see the honeymoon phase lasts a lot  along with other people it don't last  that long it lasts like a whole two  hours with me like I do think they put a  lot of features that people really  enjoyed here like uh you know especially  competitive Pokemon people like having  special moves for certain Pokemon and  it's been annoying to get some of them  so sometimes but now they have like a TM  uh it's like pretty much the item where  you get the the moves you can make that  now but it's just like I I just get I  get annoyed when they change foundations  to try to broaden the the game the open  world thing is is at this point now I  might get it it's a plague